whenever you're telling a story like
this you have to relive it and i think
that was not something that i was
expecting necessarily i knew it would be
a difficult journey but i didn't know
quite how deep i would go with it
and
it's tough it's tough to say goodbye to
something the world is mourning and hash
the beloved actress who died on friday
following a car crash that left her with
serious burns and health complications
and in the wake of her death anne's life
has sparked renewed interest
specifically the story shared in her
2001 memoir call me crazy
driving up prices among collectors and
fans
hopefully i can just give the truth you
know
i think if i had the truth given to me
when i was a kid things would have been
different so i hope i can give the truth
the late actress's book is now being
sold as a collectible the price tag
between 700
and in some places nearly a thousand
yeah and when the memoir was first
released it retailed for just over 20
bucks
just a day in december i was sitting and
i i think i was doing some yoga and i
went oh call me crazy that's what it is
because
i think i've been crazy even though i've
never been diagnosed call me crazy
details anne's trauma from childhood
abuse struggles living in the public eye
and her past relationship with ellen
degeneres for people who talk and say
abuse is not something that you should
talk about
i completely disagree abuse is something
that should be talked about so that you
don't find yourself wandering through
fields you know calling for god and
screaming for god because it can make
you crazy if you don't talk about the
pain in your life so that is part of why
i did this but also part of why i did it
is because people watched me go through
real crazy moments in my life in public
and they didn't know what was behind it
and i think it is my responsibility as a
public figure funnily enough i only
figured that i was a public figure when
people were making fun of me and calling
me crazy and i went uh maybe they need
the whole story here
and then sure feel either way about it
that you want to feel but at least you
know the story the incredible things
about ellen and my coming together is
that we both had a notion about teaching
the world about love and we bonded over
that
it's an interesting thing to be on the
other side of that because one of the
things that i've realized is that you
can't teach people to love even though
you sometimes wish that you could and i
think ellen and i thought that in
representing our love we could you know
but you can't you can't bring somebody
to love themselves or you or anybody
else and that's a that's an interesting
lesson to have learned through that
relationship that the journey is about
inside not outside but
it was still an extraordinary journey
and i met amazing people and i had an
incredible relationship
unfortunately it didn't work out but
and that's again for many many reasons
that didn't work out but it was an
amazing relationship
to give the truth it's easier than lying
you know you don't have to worry about
what anybody says it's
you at least know that you're always
telling what's happening and uh
do i think it's hard sure because it's
just like what you said it can be
confused as many different things when
you're telling the truth
however many people are going to have
however many different ideas about my
book my book is the truth of my life
but there are going to be a million
different opinions about why i'm telling
the truth
so is it hard
sure it's never fun to hear that it's
not just all good you know
but i think it's easier it certainly
feels better to me